hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel this month's q a is gonna be
pretty much
all about the next generation of
consoles just because i got so many
questions about them
so why not have it be themed also this
video is sponsored by keeps we will hear
more from them
soon but let's get to the questions i'm
gonna start out real broad here this
question is from your foe and it says
who do you think is going to win the
next generation of console wars
great question excited to answer it i
don't think the console will exist
anymore and i'm sure i've said that
before on this channel
what i guess xbox fans or playstation
fans have been
conditioned to look for is hardware
sales
which of the things sold the most i feel
like that's usually the metric
by which people define that uh the
console wall was won
it is just straight up about which box
sold more as far as the public
perception is concerned and probably
also as far as a lot of the behind the
scenes business stuff is concerned you
look at how your direct competitor is
doing and that is how you know how well
you're doing in comparison
this generation that is absolutely not
going to apply and can't
because microsoft is basically doing
something entirely different
i expect that sony will continue to do
what they have been doing
and frankly i hope they do i don't want
to lose
what playstation is doing right now and
that is providing
a lot of very very very high quality
exclusive titles and if their push is to
continue
making incredible exclusives i think the
playstation 4 had some of the best
console exclusives ever
i i very much hope that that is what
they keep doing i don't want to lose
games like bloodborne obviously from
soft it's a different situation since
it's not a first party exclusive but
you know god of war the last of us goes
to tsushima obviously
horizon zero dawn which obviously we
know we're getting a new horizon i want
them to keep doing what they're doing
what microsoft is doing is completely
different and is also kind of cool for
gamers because it means we get
these major companies both doing very
different things microsoft is not trying
to do
a terrible amount to make you buy an
xbox series x
i did speak to aaron greenberg and he
was like of course we'd love it if you
bought it so it's not like they don't
care at all
and i think that's why they keep pushing
to be like we are the best place to play
third party games because we have the
most powerful console ever made that's
clearly supposed to be an appeal for a
specific niche
but for the most part you know i've seen
people say if i can play all of these
games on pc what is the point in buying
an xbox series x
there isn't a point um you don't have to
microsoft is not trying to make you buy
an xbox series x if you already own a pc
what they want instead is for you to
subscribe to game pass
gold and for you to buy your games
through any of their various stores
so we still it seems like have sony
focusing on
selling units selling playstation 5s and
then we have microsoft focusing
on services which is also why they make
a lot of games of service games and
multiplayer games
again for me i feel like it rules
because they get both worlds
but there is basically no doubt in my
mind that the playstation 5 will sell
more units
than the xbox series x so if that's the
console world that you care about
playstations basically already won it in
my head they're two companies with two
very different strategies at this point
so those wars don't exist because only
one person is really pushing two cell
consoles
i assume that's what playstation wants i
don't actually know microsoft is
focusing on services like game pass like
xcloud
which um i know they want to have in
countries where consoles aren't really a
thing where people still have mobile
phones
so they're trying to get their millions
that way so basically
the console wars don't exist anymore so
it's just a very different landscape
it's going to be a weird one
as someone who loves single-player
experiences i feel like those are very
important to me
those are what i've always grown up
playing like i love multiplayer games
sure i play multiple every week but i am
comforted by knowing that playstation
seems to be
staying on the same course that they
have been because i'm very happy
with the games that they've come out
with same token very excited to see the
technology evolve
um and to see how streaming actually
impacts video games and some of the cool
but also very scary
stuff that could come out of that my one
biggest fear with video game streaming
services like x cloud
stadia is that they start feeding ads
into video games is that you have to
watch an ad before you get a cut scene
they also have like back-end
data manipulation potential to where
they could try to manipulate literal
in-game circumstances to make you feel
more compelled to spend money
on microtransactions because everything
is being streamed but that's like a
whole other thing
i feel like i answered that very
thoroughly that took me 10 minutes
the bomb said i had a question for you q
a for next month my question is what
would you say is the most beautiful
game you've ever played oh that's a
tough one and if we're thinking back on
the most recent console generation
red dead redemption 2 is the first game
that comes to mind i also think god of
war is really beautiful
goes to tsushima obviously really
beautiful
but there's also really stylistic games
like abzu florence
is an oddly really beautiful game um
mobile game very sketchy
very very pretty yeah i feel like i
could write a really long list of games
with really nice art styles but i'll
tell you when i got my 4k tv last year
you know
i i set it up on the stand i plugged my
consoles in it was very excited
and i sat and i had to think about what
game i was going to play first for a
pretty long time
and it was between forza horizon 4
red dead redemption 2 and god of war so
i guess
those are the ones that i consider to be
the most beautiful at that point in time
and i feel like that probably still
rings true
it is time for an ad read brought to you
by keeps did you know two out of three
guys will experience some form of
male pattern baldness by the time
they're 35 and the best way to prevent
hair loss is to do something about it
while you still have
hair at a certain point it can be too
late the convenience of keeps is that
you can get treated completely from home
you used to have to go to the doctor's
office for your hair loss prescription
now thanks to keeps you can visit a
doctor online and get hair loss
medication delivered right to your home
they make it easy and deliver your
medication every three months so you can
say goodbye to pharmacy checkout lines
and awkward doctor visits plus i do
really want to focus on the fact
that i think this is very important that
it is required that you see a doctor
this is all
licensed stuff and keeps offers the only
two fda approved hair loss products
out there so if you want to get started
go to keeps.com
alana pierce that is k e k-e-e-p-s dot
com
slash alana pierce or check the link in
my description to get started today
daniel c asks what is your favorite xbox
one game my favorite xbox one game is
probably
ahri and the will of the wisps which
came out this year i think that game is
absolutely fantastic
of course it's also on pc i don't know
if you disqualify it for that
um no i absolutely loved it i also
always want to give a big shout out to
sunset overdrive
i am so glad that the master chief
collection exists
and i pretty frequently play and
genuinely always have a good time with
sea of thieves um
i also think gears 5 is very good uh but
i'm in that game so it's cheating
and as a very big racing game fan which
i'm aware if you watch fun house you
would not guess
because i'm not good at driving in gta i
am good at it in forza
very different things uh the forza
horizon series became my favorite
racing game series as the console went
on basically
and then of course we're replay because
like pre-microsoft rare and i still have
a really big soft spot for rare in
general um it's still one of my favorite
game studios ever right now i actually
think my favorite studio is probably
platinum
but yes those are the ones that come to
mind robinson110
said for the next q a which games do you
think are going to get nominated for the
game of the year award
i think it's tough to say at this point
of the year because there's a lot more
to come but
i have no question the last of us two
will absolutely be nominated
goes to tsushima will probably be
nominated i hope ori gets nominated
um but unfortunately he does have a
bunch of technical issues
going forward i mean i feel like
cyberpunk has a pretty good chance but
we don't know yet
uh assassin's creed probably has a
pretty good chance but yeah this year i
just don't know yet it's a tough one
we'll see how i feel in a few months
lolito's thoughts said hey alana i love
your content and wanted to ask what's
your take on the console wars do you
find them good for the competition or
just annoying buzz in the industry
uh depends what you mean by industry i
think console wars largely don't exist
in my portion of the industry
so where it comes to journalists and for
the record don't consider myself a
journalist anymore
i left that years ago or just media in
general
um the console wars don't really exist
people like video games and don't
generally care
what platform you play on there are
absolutely preferences and
there are minor people who i would
consider to be more extreme
but for the most part for people
professionally working in the industry
people just like video games everyone
who works in the industry full time is
there because they like video games and
they are generally always going to have
every platform which is you know a
privilege of
working in the industry i would actually
say that even from most of my
conversations with developers
people who work for sony first party
studios like xbox games and vice versa
these people aren't like
you know butting heads competitive they
just kind of appreciate what other
developers are doing and different kinds
of video games
this is like very much broadly uh the
perception that i have
from you know having existed in this
industry with all my friends in this
industry for the last eight years
of course there are going to be people
in like certain marketing roles or
business roles who
are kind of forced to be more
competitive but it's very similar to
like the invented ign gamespot feud
people kind of think they hate each
other but they hang out all the time and
are absolutely friends and a bunch of
people are like
cross-dating you know basically in the
industry the console wars don't really
exist not for the most part it's much
more of a games community thing
um do i think that my perception of
console wars is
that it is helpful in any way no i do
think that
major players in any industry having
competitors is important but i think
that the way that people buy into it as
aggressively as they do is ultimately
not helpful it just results in a bunch
of negativity and toxicity i also feel
like there has to be something
somewhere along the lines that can't be
good for you about tying yourself like
that strongly
to a brand you know it's like i feel
like people have it as their identity
that they
support that brand at the very least if
you're on either side it means you're
missing out on cool games but from what
i can tell
it just sparks a lot of aggression
really that i just try to
completely ignore i will say the one
exception to the in the industry rule
that i have seen is david cage i went
out to dinner with david cage
and i kept trying to like figure out how
to make him like
get more comfortable or be more engaging
or like more open to conversation as
he's
i guess like a little bit reserved the
one thing that made david cage light up
was talking extremely passionately about
playstation
and not very passionately about xbox
it's literally the only one david cage i
guess i can also just say as someone who
is like
unintentionally in the console was just
based on public perception
but for me it definitely sucks i went
from a month and a half ago people
telling me i'm a sony shell and a
playstation fanboy and i'm
sold out to playstation because i liked
the last of us
and also defended parts of it part two
obviously
to then jump one month and i'm a
microsoft
shell and a sellout because i like game
puffs
so it's also just like completely
illogical i have said i was cool with
the xbox showcase
in the same way that i said i was cool
with the playstation showcase from i
think it was like 2016 maybe that most
people didn't like
and just based on which of those things
that you've seen at which time
you're gonna tell someone that they're a
fanboy and you hate them um
when the reality is people can just like
multiple things and
it's as simple as that little petra said
what are you most excited for when it
comes to the next
generation of video games i'm a big fan
of ray tracing
i love it i think it's so cool more ray
tracing in
everything i am also very excited about
um
and i really feel like this is just so
so so cool and i can't wait to see it uh
what ratchet clank is doing
which seems to be similar to the medium
as well um but
ratchet was the one that caught my eye
which is something that builds off of
like
one level in titanfall 2 and i guess
dishonored 2 does it as well
if you watch that gameplay demo from the
state of play you can see
instances where you can transport to a
different world
basically in real time without a loading
screen the ability to jump between a
full world and not just
in one level in one small segment like
in titanfall 2 is something that really
only the new consoles can do when it
comes to processing power required to do
that and i think that that opens up for
a
whole new breadth of creativity where
video games are concerned i mean sure i
want things to look pretty but that's
never been a huge drive for me as a
person who cares more about an art style
a lot of the time than about photo
realism and video games i want my ray
tracing which i guess is realism but i
still even like it in minecraft but it's
mostly stuff like that the little
touches of
how video games can evolve by virtue of
the better hardware
that i think what ration clank is doing
is going to be very interesting to see
and to see
how other games take that concept and
expand upon it again i think the medium
is doing a similar thing where you swap
between two worlds
that is not easy to do there are
definitely
some development tricks at play and yeah
it just seems really creative and cool
and i feel like a lot of people can do
very cool stuff with um massively
minimized load times
i'm excited to see more creativity is my
answer
chris hill said what do you think is the
best game of the generation
i've been planning to get drunk and make
a video of me trying to rank my top five
or top 10 because i thought it would be
really fun because i struggle
so much with like even answering what is
your favorite video game is really hard
for me so i thought that
like if i just i thought that if i just
got a little tipsy and then i like try
to put a list together
that would be super fun so i think i
might actually do that in the next
couple of weeks
right now again top of my head it
doesn't mean anything don't take this is
like 100 confirmed but
i would say it's probably the witcher 3
second is probably god of war
and then the rest of the list i i'll
figure it out oh there goes my computer
alrighty that's it for the console wars
questions we don't have any more there
are also just like a couple of questions
i get all the time that are really easy
for me to answer like
um brian said hi i love your bids but to
the question how you manage your time
when doing all these things like fun
house journalism and gaming
uh i just work constantly i'd never stop
i don't watch any tv i don't watch
movies all i do is play video games and
work
literally constantly wouldn't recommend
it for anyone there's another one
there are a couple here that say like
how do you not get bored of video games
or has working in the industry
um tired you out where video games is
concerned
i've just never had that problem i've
always just video games have been a part
of my life my whole life so i've just
never had that as an issue
so i don't know how to say how has
working in the industry changed how i
feel about video games also no i'm so
enthusiastic about the medium that even
when i'm looking at something
analytically rather than just like
having fun and not
paying attention to critical thinking
the way that
you know games are designed to be just
enjoyed um
i'm so passionate about the medium and
and how it is growing and evolving that
i
like that so it's not a problem i did
start reviewing games
because that stopped being fun i used to
love it i used to absolutely adore it i
really liked doing it at ign but at a
certain point
i don't know i just it's it's it's a
real slog
because you have to get through
something really quickly while taking
notes
and putting the whole thing together on
a time limit um and i just
after doing it for like five six years
more than any other kind of writing i
just kind of got sick of
having to play through games quickly
when i would prefer to sometimes take my
time on something
or sometimes to not finish something and
that's something i've had to learn over
time
so yeah i don't enjoy reviewing games
anymore but that doesn't mean that i
don't still you know share opinions or
impressions obviously
and the last ones that i have a bunch of
that again i've answered before but are
really easy to answer
along the lines of would you like to get
into the game's design part of business
as a part of a team creating games or
are you happy staying as an outsider
someone also basically said you always
say you like writing in video games do
you do other kinds of writing i've
definitely said this in videos before i
want to write a video game one day i've
said that on instagram i've said it on
twitter i want to write a video again
one day
yeah i do a lot of fiction writing in my
spare time
people have asked you know what am i
writing i have no interest in sharing
any of it like maybe i will eventually
but i really just do it for me so i
don't i don't
feel compelled to have other people read
any of it i feel like that's a strange
approach to writing books but i just
don't i like
i like doing them and completing them
and experiencing that but i don't care
about
anything being published so i don't know
if that makes me weird but yes i
absolutely have always loved that part
of writing as well i've been writing
books since
i could literally write um so i feel
like it was always going to be one of
the other no matter what i was going to
end up in video games because that's
been
like one of the things i've been most
passionate about my whole life and the
other thing is writing so it was either
gonna be write a video game write about
video games
and i think i will probably do both and
that is it from me today
everyone i'm alana i will see you guys
next time